[Music]  you may not believe it  but there is magic all around us  there are times it can be hard to find  did you bring your garbage to school  but sometimes extra the magic  finds us look at you uncle casey  so cute i'm so red how big is he gonna  get  that depends doesn't it on what on how  much you love him  i wish you were big and strong and the  world could nervous  [Music]  we're gonna be late for school  [Music]  [Music]  why don't we get you on the scale here  bud i'm just gonna write  heavy what if you found someone who made  you feel like you could do anything  [Music]  i heard no no oh no  [Music]  well you don't see that every day maybe  it's time to feed  [Music]  bye